there are a lot of things that I would
do if I had Scarlett Johansson's voice
in my ear doing whatever I wanted her is
directed by Spike Jones and stars
Joaquin Phoenix Amy Adams Chris Pratt
and the voice of Scarlett Johansson this
is a vision of the not so distant future
we're walking in Phoenix gets this OS
system that he uploads to his computer
this kind of like its own sentient being
it is an AI it has a lot of intelligence
it has the ability to evolve and learn
things you can pick a male voice or a
female voice he of course picks a female
voice and that is Scarlett Johansson
they strike up a relationship together
and this relationship goes on a lot of
really interesting ways and you get to
learn a lot about humans and technology
and the way those two things are
starting to become one in certain ways
her is an excellent movie and one of the
reasons I love this movie so much is
because of the realistic characters I
really started to believe that these
people were real even Scarlett
Johansson's character Samantha I
completely bought her as a being even
though it was just her voice I heard a
lot of Oscar buzz about her voice work
which is you know a rarity but she
really was great in this movie Joaquin
Phoenix once again this guy is an actor
and he can really inhabit a character
and I totally believe this was a real
person that's one of the great things
about the way this film was directed and
written both by Spike Jonze his
characterizations were so interesting
and really believable and I loved the
humor in the movie too it was also a
very funny movie that was something that
surprised me because I knew who's gonna
be kind of silly and fun but I was
really surprised that all the humor that
was in it and a lot of it was really gut
busting to me but what really struck me
about this movie was just how invested I
was in this relationship I can't believe
that just her voice and this guy and
that's all I needed
I was so invested emotionally it really
blew me away because it's kind of tough
to think about that you know it's really
just a voice in his ear but you get to
watch his character grow and change so
much through her and she does the same
thing and she has all these really
interesting ways of learning about life
and it's so original really I haven't
seen a movie quite like this and I think
that's a cause to celebrate this movie
because I think it's pretty cool that
they're able to still make
awesome original ideas even if it is
twisted around certain things that we've
seen before that's basically what all
movies are it's just a different version
of something we've seen before but this
movie felt so new and fresh
Joaquin Phoenix as I said was terrific
in the movie it's really beautifully
written it's wonderfully shot I really
like the music by Arcade Fire also Amy
Adams and Chris Pratt were really good
in the movie too they had sort of small
roles Amy Adams role was definitely more
important and she was terrific in the
movie all in all I wish there were more
movies like her because it's just a
different movie that you can really get
into as I watched it I just kept
thinking to myself I really am into this
world and into these characters and I
really started to care about all these
people and that's what I want from a
movie a movie to transport me to a place
that feels real that actually feels
inhabitable and that's what her did for
me I thought it was a terrific movie if
you guys get a chance to see it it is
finally opening wide it took forever to
come to me it opened December 18th in
New York and LA I've been like I want to
see this movie it was terrific I'm gonna
give it an A so guys if you have seen
the movie let me know what you thought
of it below what's your thoughts on the
way humans and Technology are going
because the movie has a lot of shots
just showing humans staring into their
phones and you see that a lot even
nowadays and it's it's definitely got
some stuff to say about that guys thanks
very much for watching and as always if
you like this you can click right here
and get stuck on eyes
[Music]
so really quick I were to let you guys
know something pretty cool that I'm very
happy about the website audible.com has
chosen to sponsor my videos they like
what I'm doing and they want to help me
basically and through me they're
allowing any of my viewers to get a free
audiobook if you guys want to download
an audiobook it's completely free that
giving me my own URL address that you
can go to and it's literally just my
gift to you through audible if you like
audiobooks if you like hearing your
favorite stars read certain books you
can do that through audible.com to your
phone or tablet I've left that link in
the description below it is audible.com
slash Chris that's audible.com slash
Chris if you guys want a free book
that's awesome these guys like my videos
I like them I've used them in the past
as a service I really like the book
Carey Sissy Spacek actually reads it
which is pretty awesome if you guys
would also like a free audiobook you can
go to that link you can support me you
can support audible at the same time
because they like what I'm doing here
and that's awesome thank you very much
guys have a good day